die debatte hat für uns erfolgt mein
kollege ralf schuler jetzt doch bei mir
im studio greift das allererste was
einem aufgefallen ist es gab gerade
einige zwischenrufe pfiffe bei der rede
von angela merkel was hatten diese zu
bedeuten und ist das normal
das ist inzwischen normal geworden die
afg hat sich sichtlich bemüht durch
zwischenrufe die kanzlerin aus dem
konzept zu bringen
sie hat dann auch gestalt der auftakt
rede von alice weil der
fraktionsvorsitzenden ein total verriss
der merkelschen politik geliefert das
gehört zum standard und ist bei so einer
generaldebatte eigentlich schon leider
zu erwarten gewesen
wir haben gerade eine kanzlerin gesehen
die sehr filigran und sehr detailliert
noch mal die krone regeln noch mal
vorgelesen hat und sie noch mal geradezu
ausgebreitet hat um sie noch mal am
podium aus zu erzählen da dachte man
eigentlich schon na ja es ist die
nüchterne allüren lose kanzlerin wie
immer auch bei so einer großen
generaldebatte bleibt sie sachlich
bleibt sie nüchtern
am ende wurde sie dann doch noch
emotional das war schon sehr interessant
diese generale button haben wir eine
lange tradition jetzt ist es die letzte
vor angela merkel nächstes jahr die
wahlen dann worum geht es überhaupt bei
dieser aussprache im bundestag heute und
generell wofür sind diese general
gemangelt
also das königsrecht des parlaments ist
ja der haushalt darüber wird alles
gesteuert das geld was man den
ministerien zur verfügung stellt ist am
ende entscheidend dafür welche politik
gemacht werden kann
und da gibt es immer am zweiten tag der
haushaltsdebatte der haushaltswoche im
herbst gibt es die generaldebatte über
den kanzleretat
das ist eigentlich der etappe 04 das ist
ein unspektakulärer kleiner punkte weil
er das kanzleramt erfahrungsgemäß nicht
den größten etatposten hat in dem ja
3,38 milliarden euro relativ klein aber
es wird genutzt um eine
generalabrechnung mit der politik der
kanzlerin oder des kanzlers jeweils zu
veranstalten und eine große aussprache
zu
etablieren und das war auch diesmal so
im nächsten jahr wird es ist richtig
gesagt ausfallen weil er die neue
regierung dann über dieses geld verfügt
und da kann es eben auch heute zum
großen schlagabtausch ehemann hatte
überlegt ob möglicherweise die kanzlerin
da ist nun ihre letzte generaldebatte
ist zu einem großen emotionalen auftritt
nach 16 jahren kanzlerschaft ausholen
würde das hat sie nicht getan sie blieb
sich an vielleicht auch gar nicht so gut
in diesem sinn sie sich selbst treu aber
am ende war rannten sie sich nochmal
ganz emotional an bürger und abgeordnete
appellierte die krone regeln einzuhalten
sagte wir werden das leben was wir
kannten zurückbekommen wenn wir jetzt
uns an die regeln halten auf unseren
nachbarn achten
all das was man die jahre von ihr immer
wieder gefordert hatte dass sie eine
große emotionale rede hält das kann nun
ganz zum schluss in der letzten letzten
redebeitrag der generaldebatte nachricht
nur breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren